Okay, here we go. This is going to be a smartless episode. Let's tune up the ears, get the wax out. What are you doing? The papers are getting set. The prep is done. Okay, ready? Here we go.
好的，我们开始吧。这将是一期Smartless节目。把耳朵调好，把耳垢清理干净。你在干什么？稿子准备好了。准备工作完成了。好了，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。
Are you guys? Guys, guys, guys, it's an all-new smartless. Oh, God. Smartless. Smart. Smart. Smart. Okay, hey guys, look, wait, check this out.
你们准备好了吗？伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，这是一期全新的Smartless。哦，天哪。Smartless。Smart。Smart。Smart。好了，嘿伙计们，看，等等，看看这个。
Oh, sure, yeah, yeah, start right away. Yeah, have you been preparing, Sean? You see that, look at the sign. Construction? No, that sign, right where my finger is. Chicago Theater. Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow. Did you know that a week ago
哦，当然，是啊，是啊，马上开始。是啊，你一直在准备吗，肖恩？你看到那个了吗，看那个标志。施工？不，那个标志，就在我手指的地方。芝加哥剧院。哦，哇，哇，哇，哇。你知道一周前
that you were going to be staying in that apartment? I knew, I knew the name of it, but I didn't know where it was. Yeah, Sean, for the listener, Sean started his stay there. What is it going to be like a multi-month stay in Chicago, right? The first night he was there was Valentine's, and appropriately he and Scotty saw a couple consummating Valentine's right across the street. And like in kind of like, it wasn't even like, it was all the lights were on. it was somewhat impromptu. We won't get into the graphic details of it,
你要住在那间公寓里吗？我知道，我知道它的名字，但我不知道它在哪里。是啊，肖恩，对于听众来说，肖恩开始在那里住了。那将是几个月的芝加哥之行，对吧？他去的第一晚是情人节，很应景的是，他和斯科蒂看到街对面有一对情侣在过情人节。而且就像，甚至都不像，所有的灯都开着。这有点即兴。我们就不去深究那些细节了，
but it was clearly not a planned consummation. No, all parties were upright, is the point. It was half a wobbly age. Isn't that wild? And Scottie's like, I go, what are you looking at? And he's like, come over to this window. How long was he looking out the window before you noticed he was staring? Quite a while.
但这显然不是计划好的。不，重点是所有当事人都站着。那真是太疯狂了，不是吗？斯科蒂说，我问，你在看什么？他说，过来看看这扇窗户。在你注意到他在盯着看之前，他在窗边看了多久？好一会儿。
It was a minute. And he kept saying, and he kept saying, come look at these people in love right he kept saying look at these people i mean he they were going this is love in case you didn't know it's valentine's day okay now do you think they wanted to be seen that's why the shades were up yeah no i think people are just used to living well will you can speak to this you've lived in new york city uh do you just get used to the fact that people might be watching you or do you well that i think you go back and forth i think that you are you have moments where you're like oh my god and then you also have moments you're like
有一分钟。他一直说，他一直说，快来看这些相爱的人，他一直说看这些相爱的人，我的意思是，他们当时在说，如果你不知道的话，这就是爱，今天是情人节，好了，你觉得他们想被人看到吗？这就是为什么窗帘是拉开的？是啊，不，我觉得人们只是习惯了生活，威尔，你可以谈谈这个，你在纽约市住过，呃，你只是习惯了人们可能会看着你，还是你，嗯，我觉得你会反复思考，我觉得你有时候会觉得，哦，天哪，然后你也会有那种时刻，你会觉得
you just live your life and you don't think about it you can't you can't think about it all the time I mean you could pull the shades down sure um I will I would suggest that those people who are engaged in that in that moment uh didn't care uh and in fact that that probably was there to heighten their experience
你只是过你的生活，你不会去想它，你不能，你不能一直去想它。我的意思是，你可以把窗帘拉下来，当然，嗯，我会建议那些在那一刻做那种事的人，呃，并不在乎，事实上，那可能反而增强了他们的体验。
now Shawnee you're you're back out on the road um how's uh we'll get to our guests here apologies but uh shani how's the first few days of rehearsal going on having regrets how's oscar levant so sean's doing a it's not a musical right it's got some music in it it's a play no no it's a play it's a play it's a play it's so he's there now he's a weekend of rehearsals and uh it's it's pretty arduous to to rehearse a play for the listener and sean are you loving it or or having regrets oh my god i love it so much i mean it's a ton of work but um thank you for asking it's it's uh yeah it's a ton of work but but really rewarding you know what i love the most is the we're in the process of
现在肖尼，你又在路上了，嗯，怎么样，呃，我们会谈到我们的嘉宾，抱歉，但是，肖尼，排练的前几天怎么样，有后悔吗，奥斯卡·黎凡特怎么样？所以肖恩正在做，这不是音乐剧，对吧？里面有一些音乐，这是一部戏，不，不，这是一部戏，这是一部戏，这是一部戏，所以他现在在那里，他排练了一个周末，呃，排练一部戏对听众和肖恩来说相当艰苦，你喜欢它还是后悔了？哦，天哪，我太喜欢了，我的意思是，工作量很大，但是，嗯，谢谢你的提问，它，呃，是的，工作量很大，但真的很有回报，你知道我最喜欢的是我们正在
sitting around talking about the play page by page making sure everything makes sense and the backstory informs what the characters are doing it's kind of is it the first time the play is being done yeah it's a brand new play by doug right who won the pulitzer for i am my own wife and he wrote the movie quills and amazing writer well that's plug doug for sure you know does he have a website oh by the way it's called goodnight oscar it's called goodnight oscar oh god we know and We have told every audience across the country knows Oscar Levant backstage at the Tonight Show. Nobody's going to go to the play now. Everybody feels like they've already seen it.
坐在一起讨论剧本，一页一页地确保一切都有意义，背景故事为角色的行为提供依据，这是这部戏第一次上演吗？是的，这是道格·赖特的一部全新剧作，他曾凭借《我即我妻》获得普利策奖，他还写了电影《鹅毛笔》，了不起的作家，好吧，那一定要给道格打个广告，你知道他有网站吗？哦，顺便说一句，它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》，它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》，哦，天哪，我们知道，我们告诉了全国各地的每一位观众，奥斯卡·黎凡特在《今夜秀》后台。现在没人会去看这部戏了。每个人都觉得他们已经看过了。
Well, maybe they'll check out Murderville again. Yeah, exactly. Let's give that another. It's not a bad idea. That's not a bad idea. How's that doing, Will? People seem to really be enjoying it. It's been very nice to see people enjoy it and have fun with it.
嗯，也许他们会再看看《谋杀小镇》。是啊，没错。让我们再给它一次机会。这不是个坏主意。这不是个坏主意。威尔，那个做得怎么样了？人们似乎真的很喜欢它。看到人们喜欢它并从中获得乐趣，真是太好了。
Listener, that's a show on Netflix called Murderville that Will Arnett brought to all of us. It's a fair to us. And, you know, well, so we go from that. So from Good Night Oscar to Murderville to the other big question we got a lot on the tour, which is Jason, when are the final six episodes of us are going out? It's seven, but not a big deal. Seven. I don't know.
听众朋友们，那是Netflix上的一档节目，叫《谋杀小镇》，是威尔·阿奈特带给我们的。这对我们来说很公平。而且，你知道，好吧，所以我们从那儿开始。所以从《晚安，奥斯卡》到《谋杀小镇》，再到我们在巡演中被问到的另一个大问题，那就是杰森，我们最后六集什么时候播出？是七集，但没什么大不了的。七集。我不知道。
I wanted to surprise people with the seventh. Sorry. There's a bonus. Yeah. After the credits, there's one more. They're going to announce that soon, but it's going to say. I cannot say, but it will be soon. All right.
我想用第七集给人们一个惊喜。抱歉。有一个彩蛋。是啊。片尾字幕之后，还有一集。他们很快就会宣布，但它会说。我不能说，但很快就会有。好了。
Here comes our guest, y'all. Okay, okay, all right. Sean, well, today I get into a little bit of trouble with you guys. I apologize. I know that you hate it when I bring an academic on or a scientist, big brains in general. But this guy seems to really just hold on. He seems to really be liked by those who have taken his class. All right?
我们的嘉宾来了，各位。好了，好了，好吧。肖恩，嗯，今天我和你们惹上了一点麻烦。我道歉。我知道当我在节目中请来学者或科学家，或者一般的大脑时，你们会很讨厌。但这家伙似乎真的很，等等。他似乎真的很受那些上过他课的人的欢迎。好了吗？
He's been teaching filmmaking for almost 30 years now and out of some of the top institutions in town. He's taught his students mostly through doing in that he's managed together the funds necessary to himself. make nine films on subjects as odd as a single digit, nighttime mucus, party drinks, hemophilia, major golf tournament, addiction, haunted textiles, and Italian candy. And if you can believe it, these films have yielded an 11 Academy Award nominations. Most importantly, though, he's got four kids, a house in the valley, and married to the coolest woman, we three know. Gang, it's Paul Thomas Anderson. No.
他教电影制作已经快30年了，在城里一些顶尖的机构任教。他主要是通过实践来教导学生，他设法筹集了必要的资金，自己制作了九部电影，题材五花八门，有单数、夜间粘液、派对饮料、血友病、大型高尔夫锦标赛、成瘾、闹鬼纺织品和意大利糖果。如果你们能相信的话，这些电影获得了11项奥斯卡提名。不过最重要的是，他有四个孩子，在山谷里有一栋房子，还娶了我们三个认识的最酷的女人。伙计们，他是保罗·托马斯·安德森。不。
No. Yes. Oh, my God. Hello. Oh, my gosh. Hi, guys. It's so good to see you. Did you guys have a guest with that list of subject matters?
不。是的。哦，天哪。你好。哦，天哪。嗨，伙计们。见到你们真好。你们猜到有那个题材列表的嘉宾了吗？
You really had me reeling on that. Did I bury it good? That's a great intro. I worked on that for a full nine minutes this morning. Paul, would you have been able to guess yourself with that intro? Come on. Now, let's guess it. So a single digit, which one is that, man?
你真的让我晕头转向了。我埋得好吗？那是个很棒的开场白。我今天早上花了整整九分钟准备那个。保罗，如果换做是你，你能猜到那个开场白吗？来吧。现在，让我们猜猜。所以单数，那是哪一个，伙计？
I did it in order. A single digit, obviously, is heart aid. Nighttime mucus? Nighttime mucus Come on Boogie nights, y'all Party drinks Oh my god
我是按顺序来的。单数，显然是《硬八》。夜间粘液？夜间粘液，来吧，《不羁夜》，伙计们，派对饮料，哦，天哪。
Oh my gosh Okay, party drinks We've got Punch drunk love Humophilia There will be blood Major golf tournament Obviously the master
哦，天哪，好了，派对饮料，我们有《私恋失调》，血友病，《血色将至》，大型高尔夫锦标赛，显然是《大师》。
Addiction is inherent vice Haunted textiles We know and love Phantom Thread An Italian candy Out in theaters now The Valley Famous Pizza record store
成瘾是《性本恶》，闹鬼纺织品，我们熟知并喜爱的《魅影缝匠》，还有意大利糖果，现在正在影院上映，山谷，著名的披萨唱片店。
That's incredible All right. Pretty good. I'm so proud of myself, Paul. You can see I'm just beaming. He's so. Guys, we can't do early morning records. I'm still up from last night.
太不可思议了。好了。相当不错。我真为自己感到骄傲，保罗。你可以看到我简直在发光。他太。伙计们，我们不能在清晨录音。我昨晚还没睡呢。
That's like the USA Today crossword version. You know what I mean? Oh, man. Wait, but Oscar Levant is one of my heroes. Really? Oh, really? Oh, you go. You two.
那就像《今日美国》填字游戏的版本。你知道我的意思吗？哦，伙计。等等，但奥斯卡·黎凡特是我的英雄之一。真的吗？哦，真的吗？哦，你去吧。你们两个。
He's amazing, isn't he? Yes. You know, there's a great Oscar Levant show that he did that was here on KTLA Channel. and Fred Astaire was one of the... That's exactly right. It was impossible to find forever and ever and ever. I have the whole thing if you want it.
他很了不起，不是吗？是的。你知道，奥斯卡·黎凡特做过一个很棒的节目，就在KTLA频道。弗雷德·阿斯泰尔是其中之一……完全正确。那东西永远都找不到。如果你想要的话，我有全套。
No, well, but I remember it was this impossible to find thing. And then when this thing, YouTube came around, I remember thinking, I'll see if this thing can really find something I want. And I put it in the Oscar Levant show, and there it was. I said, oh, my God, I like YouTube. It was there. Is it great? Yeah, yeah.
不，嗯，但我记得那是一个根本找不到的东西。然后当这个东西，YouTube出现的时候，我记得我想，我看看这个东西能不能真的找到我想要的东西。我输入了奥斯卡·黎凡特秀，它就在那里。我说，哦，天哪，我喜欢YouTube。它就在那里。它很棒吗？是啊，是啊。
Dear Mr. YouTube, great job. what's your while I'm thinking of it because my brain doesn't hold stuff well the first shot in Magnolia was that when you go through the hallways and you go onto the sound stage
亲爱的YouTube先生，干得好。顺便问一下，因为我的大脑记不住东西，在《木兰花》的第一个镜头里，那是当你穿过走廊进入摄影棚的时候吗？
isn't that the Tonight Show stage at yes right speaking of the Tonight Show Oscar Levant on it's right yeah what does they call it officially it's NBC it's where the Tonight Show with Johnny Carson you know they did that
那不是《今夜秀》的舞台吗？是的，没错，说到《今夜秀》，奥斯卡·黎凡特就在上面，没错，是的，他们正式称它为什么？那是NBC，那是约翰尼·卡森的《今夜秀》，你知道他们做了那个。
but they also did the local news there they had you know i remember a big deal was that we were shooting and we had to uh we had it was the days of paul moyer do you remember paul moyer and um we just needed to move his space over you know a couple spots and it was like you know three days of negotiations to move paul moyer's spot he was not having it and it was on a sunday he wasn't even shooting oh my god he wasn't even there he just didn't want his stuff messed with he just didn't want his spot messed with Somehow I remember, I don't know how I'm remembering this, he had a bright, I think it was a bright red 9-11 D.P. Targa, like one of those with the big whale tales.
但他们也在那里做当地新闻，他们有，你知道，我记得当时我们正在拍摄，我们不得不，呃，那是保罗·莫耶的时代，你还记得保罗·莫耶吗？而且，嗯，我们只是需要把他的位置挪一下，你知道，几个位置，那就像，你知道，三天的谈判才挪动了保罗·莫耶的位置，他根本不干，而且那是在周日，他甚至都没在拍摄，哦，天哪，他甚至都不在那里，他只是不想让他的东西被动，他只是不想让他的位置被动。不知怎么的，我记得，我不知道我是怎么记住这个的，他有一辆亮红色的911 Targa，就像那种带有大鲸鱼尾巴的。
I like that. Yeah. Did he cut you off once on follow? No, I just remember being taken that a local newsman would have some big ass flashy, cool car, and he pulled it off. That guy, very, very cool. Yeah, he was a hand-to-hand fight with him and Ron Burgundy would be great. It's a very similar kind of, you know.
我喜欢那个。是啊。他有没有在路上切过你的车？不，我只是记得很惊讶，一个当地的新闻播音员竟然会有这么大、这么炫酷的车，而且他真的开得很好。那家伙，非常，非常酷。是啊，他和罗恩·勃艮第打一架会很棒。这是一种非常相似的，你知道。
Speaking of cool network newsmen, kind of, a little bit of a reach, your dad was the voice of ABC for all of my years growing up in Los Angeles. Oh, really? Yeah. Like, if I played that voice for you, you'd knock you out. You'd be like, oh, my God, that's Paul's dad. No question there. I just want to mention that as something very, very cool.
说到酷炫的网络新闻播音员，某种程度上，有点牵强，你父亲是我在洛杉矶长大的那些年里ABC的声音。哦，真的吗？是啊。如果我为你播放那个声音，你会惊呆的。你会说，哦，天哪，那是保罗的爸爸。毫无疑问。我只是想提一下，这是一件非常，非常酷的事情。
Well, actually, so Paul, we've talked about this briefly before once. Because you mentioned, your dad was the voice of ABCs, you said, and he was like the original real promo guy on networks. Yeah, yeah. And my recollection is, and so I'm going to say this, and then you can tell me what you know about this, and if I'm wrong. He would record the promos for all the network.
嗯，实际上，所以保罗，我们之前简短地谈过一次。因为你提到，你父亲是ABC的声音，你说，他是网络上最初的真正宣传员。是啊，是啊。我的记忆是，所以我要说这个，然后你可以告诉我你知道什么，如果我错了。他会为所有的网络录制宣传片。
And the promo guys are, when you watch a show, when you're watching a network and you hear, coming up tonight at 8 p.m. It's an all-new, blah, blah, blah. Followed by by. Oh, that was your dad? That was your dad? And your dad would sit in the room with the engineer
而宣传员是，当你观看一个节目时，当你观看一个网络，你听到，今晚8点即将播出。这是一个全新的，等等，等等。紧随其后的是。哦，那是你爸爸？那是你爸爸？你爸爸会和工程师坐在房间里。
right next to the board, and he had a 4-16, a shotgun mic, and he was the first guy to do that in that way. Is that right? Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. I don't know for sure if that's exactly that technical thing, but that the image of that shotgun mic, you know, he would never go into the booth.
就在控制台旁边，他有一个4-16，一个枪式麦克风，他是第一个那样做的人。是这样吗？嗯，嗯。我不确定那是否完全是那种技术上的东西，但那个枪式麦克风的形象，你知道，他从不进录音棚。
He wanted to do it in the control room. Was he, because he was actually in real time telling the guy how to modulate his voice and do all the EQ and stuff? I think that had something to do with it, too, And I think he was smart enough or done it enough to know, like, I'm not going in the booth. I'm going to be with you guys.
他想在控制室里做。是因为他实际上是在实时告诉那个人如何调节他的声音，做所有的均衡器之类的东西吗？我想那也和它有关系，而且我想他足够聪明，或者做过足够多次，知道，我不进录音棚。我要和你们在一起。
You know, it's going to be exactly the same. I'm not, you know. He also liked to smoke while he was doing it, too. And I think he was out of weird. Willie likes that. Willie does a little of that. Not in the booth, not anymore. But I will say that, like, and then I'll get out of the weeds on this.
你知道，这会完全一样。我不是，你知道。他还喜欢在做的时候抽烟。而且我想他有点怪。威利喜欢那样。威利也做一点。不在录音棚里，不再做了。但我会说，然后我就不再纠结这个了。
So traditionally, all the voiceover guys, especially in New York, where a lot of it used to be done back in the day, everybody used the mic that's a very common that I do have over here and what we refer to as an 87 a U-87 and it's a great microphone
所以传统上，所有的配音员，特别是在纽约，过去很多工作都是在那里完成的，每个人都使用一种非常常见的麦克风，我这里也有，我们称之为87，一个U-87，它是一个很棒的麦克风。
oh thanks well your dad changed that by using that shotgun mic and he forever changed and it became the West Coast microphone that all so whenever I would come out here and go to a recording studio they'd always have a shotgun mic
哦，谢谢，威尔，你父亲通过使用那个枪式麦克风改变了这一点，他永远地改变了它，它成为了西海岸的麦克风，所以每当我来到这里去录音室时，他们总是有枪式麦克风。
and it was because of your dad that that became the standard out of here is that like the Johnny Carson one that was on his desk is that what a shotgun mic is what is that No, that... No. Okay, bye everybody. Oh, see you later, Sean.
是因为你父亲，它才成为了这里的标准，那是约翰尼·卡森桌上的那个吗？枪式麦克风是什么？那是什么？不，那个……不。好吧，再见大家。哦，回头见，肖恩。
So, Paul, you did not know that, huh? No, that sounds fantastic to me, and it doesn't seem too far from accurate. Even, you know, he did obsess over that kind of stuff, and I probably passed a little bit of it on to me. Were you close to him? Yeah, very. Oh, that's nice.
所以，保罗，你不知道那个，是吧？不，那听起来对我来说太棒了，而且看起来离事实不远。即使，你知道，他确实对那种事情很着迷，我可能也传了一点点给我。你和他亲近吗？是啊，非常亲近。哦，那真好。
I got to go, you know, I had that opportunity to go to Prospect and Talmadge, which was where he would go to work at ABC. Downtown. And, you know, generally, that was sort of my first taste of being around anything that was show business related, and that was magical to me. How old were you at that point?
我得走了，你知道，我有机会去Prospect和Talmadge，那是他去ABC工作的地方。市中心。而且，你知道，通常那是我的第一次体验，接触到任何与演艺事业相关的东西，那对我来说很神奇。那时候你多大？
Anywhere between the ages of probably five and, you know, nine, 75 to 70. Did it strike you as being like a peculiar thing for your dad to do? I can say from my own experience, And I ask this because I say to my kids sometimes, like, it's when they do stuff or I do stuff or they come in a work-related environment. I'm like, it's weird, right?
大概在五岁到，你知道，九岁之间，75年到70年。你觉得你父亲做这件事很奇怪吗？我可以从我自己的经验说，我问这个是因为我有时会对我的孩子们说，就像，当他们做事情或者我做事情，或者他们进入一个与工作相关的环境时。我说，这很奇怪，对吧？
That this is what you're, because it's weird to me if my dad had done it. And I sort of acknowledge it. Was it, did it seem strange or just because it was your dad? It seems strange only because it was not, I was proud of him, but no one else could recognize this, the pride, you know?
因为如果我爸爸做了这件事，对我来说很奇怪。我有点承认这一点。那是，它看起来很奇怪，还是仅仅因为那是你爸爸？它看起来很奇怪，只是因为它不是，我为他感到骄傲，但没有人能认出这种骄傲，你知道？
It's such as behind-the-scenes gig, there's nothing. there's nothing kind of famous about it you know you don't walk down the street and somebody say like wow there he is you know or your dad's a baseball player he's hit my mind it's like well you you know there's no recognition to it
这真是一个幕后的工作，没什么。没什么出名的，你知道，你走在街上，不会有人说，哇，他就在那儿，你知道，或者你爸爸是个棒球运动员，这让我很惊讶，就像，好吧，你，你知道，它没有认可度。
really it was this but that's what he loved about it so much was that he could just kind of have this independent life coyoteing around town and you know doing his work and getting paid for it so you're sitting there you're watching kind of the sausage get made for television and in some
真的，这就是他如此热爱它的原因，因为他可以过这种独立的生活，在城里四处奔波，你知道，做他的工作并为此获得报酬，所以你坐在那里，你看着电视的制作过程，在某种程度上。
aspect and were you were you at that point starting to gather these images and interest in this process and what it oh these are the people that are behind the curtain that create at least this lane of fake life and and and that started to build an idea for you about what you might want to do or get or can you can you track the moment that you thought uh i i want to do something like this i can't remember because it for as long as my memories are there i've wanted to to make films for sure but you have to remember i mean jason you'll remember that there was like such a dividing line between making films and making television yeah yeah television back then was like
而且你当时是否开始收集这些图像和对这个过程的兴趣，以及它，哦，这些人是幕后推手，至少创造了这种虚假生活的通道，而且这开始为你建立一个关于你可能想做什么的想法，或者你可以，你可以追踪你认为，呃，我想做这样的事情的时刻吗？我不记得了，因为只要我有记忆，我就肯定想拍电影，但你必须记住，我的意思是杰森，你会记得，拍电影和做电视之间有这样一条分界线，是啊，是啊，当时的电视就像。
you know anybody can do it you know right movies it was like this this gold ring like not everybody gets to make movies you know right so you started to experiment with little home movie and it's not it's not an uncommon story right and no it's the same exact story as everybody else But I had the camaraderie and it was so crazy. Now, I mean, I look around my life right now and I see my relationship to all the people in dark rooms that I work with engineers and things like this. It's the entire process of making a movie.
你知道，任何人都能做，你知道，对吧，电影，它就像这个金戒指，不是每个人都能拍电影，你知道，对吧？所以你开始尝试拍摄小家庭电影，这不是，这不是一个不常见的故事，对吧？不，这和每个人的故事完全一样，但我有那种情谊，这太疯狂了。现在，我的意思是，我环顾我的生活，我看到了我和我一起工作的暗室里所有人的关系，工程师之类的。这是制作电影的整个过程。
And you're like, this is exactly what my dad did. You go to a dark room each day and, you know, trying to make something happen. And the friendships that he had with those guys, I look back and I think, I was really inspired by I always just thought that's what a friendship was
你就像，这正是我的父亲所做的。你每天去一个暗室，你知道，试图让事情发生。他和那些家伙的友谊，我回想起来，我想，我真的很受启发，我一直以为这就是友谊。
you know these kind of he was very close with all these technicians and guys that he worked with so those are the people that were around our house yeah my
你知道，这些，他和他一起工作的所有技术人员和家伙都很亲近，所以那些就是我们家周围的人，是啊，我的。
one of my first experiences were people that were very very close with the crew or at least a full understanding of the importance of the crew as opposed to sort of this this sort of terrible
我最早的经历之一是那些与剧组非常非常亲近的人，或者至少是对剧组的重要性有充分理解的人，而不是那种可怕的。
traditional kind of look at like oh you know the that's you know some people look at crew as sort of soldiers and that, you know, the folks that are in front of the camera, the ones that are super important when it could, when the, when the opposite is actually the truth. And so was that, did that start then understanding that, oh my God, this is, this is really difficult and there's actually nobody on the set there that doesn't need to be there.
传统的看法，就像，哦，你知道，那是，你知道，有些人把剧组看作士兵，你知道，那些在镜头前的人，才是超级重要的，而事实恰恰相反。所以那是，那是从那时开始理解的吗，哦，天哪，这，这真的很难，而且片场里其实没有一个人是不需要在那里的。
Well, the only people that don't need to be there are like studio executives and producers. And, you know, what I learned probably from my dad, it was like, whoever's, whoever's, you know, kick all the people out of the room that are not completely, completely essential to the product, you know. You learn pretty quickly who isn't, you know, they scatter. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，唯一不需要在那里的人是像制片厂高管和制片人。而且，你知道，我可能从我父亲那里学到的是，就像，无论谁，无论谁，你知道，把所有对产品不是完全，完全必不可少的人都赶出房间，你知道。你很快就会知道谁不是，你知道，他们会散开。是啊。是啊。
So grabbing those early video cameras, movie cameras, stuff like that, that's sort of a pretty common story where you kind of point a camera at stuff and you kind of take little kid films and little army men and that's not uncommon. But what about the writing part? Do you remember your first experience? looking at a blank piece of paper and trying to figure out how to start from zero.
所以拿起那些早期的摄像机，电影摄影机之类的东西，那是一个相当普遍的故事，你对着东西指指点点，你拍摄小孩子的电影和玩具兵，这并不罕见。但写作部分呢？你还记得你的第一次经历吗？看着一张空白的纸，试图弄清楚如何从零开始。
Do you remember that being humbling or surprisingly easy? That's a really good question because I think you're right that the story of, you know, the filmmaker with the 8mm camera and then onto the video cameras, like there's a million of them and that's generally how everybody starts. But the writing part always excited me because I liked it. I think I got lucky that I liked it. I liked putting paper into a typewriter and typing out ideas.
你还记得那让你感到谦卑还是出奇地容易吗？这是一个非常好的问题，因为我觉得你是对的，那个关于，你知道，拿着8毫米摄像机然后转向摄像机的电影制作人的故事，就像有成千上万个，这通常是每个人开始的方式。但写作部分总是让我兴奋，因为我喜欢它。我想我很幸运，我喜欢它。我喜欢把纸放进打字机，打出想法。
And I liked seeing it on the page. I liked looking at that idea. I don't know. From an early age, I've always liked writing and formulating things on paper. And when you learn on a typewriter, you learn how to make it right the first time because the last thing that you want to do
我喜欢在纸上看到它。我喜欢看着那个想法。我不知道。从很小的时候起，我就一直喜欢写作和在纸上构思东西。当你用打字机学习时，你学会了如何第一次就把它写对，因为你最不想做的事情。
is go through that and I had the one script You still use a typewriter? No, I don't I mean from time to time I will just for fun to mix it up But no I don't use a typewriter anymore
就是经历那个，我有一个剧本，你还在用打字机吗？不，我不，我的意思是，时不时地我会为了好玩而换换口味，但不，我不再用打字机了。
But I remember the one script that I had I think I have to credit my mother for this Is I had the script for Holy Grail Oh wow Monty Python Monty Python It was published as a little book
但我记得我有的那个剧本，我想我得把这个归功于我的母亲，是我有《圣杯》的剧本，哦，哇，蒙提·派森，蒙提·派森，它作为一本小书出版了。
And I loved that movie so much So this is like probably 8, 78 or 79. By the way, they're both like Monty Python. No, the actual Holy Grail, you... Jesus. We're helping Tracy, okay? So I had the... What was the script for that?
我太喜欢那部电影了，所以这大概是78年或79年。顺便说一句，他们都像蒙提·派森。不，真正的圣杯，你……天哪。我们在帮助特雷西，好吗？所以我有了……那个剧本是什么？
And then I just copied that. I just copied how the formatting was of that. It was a great way to learn. So I think writing is either something that you like doing or you don't like doing. I mean, you know, it's... Yeah. I got a dumb dummy question.
然后我就抄了那个。我只是抄了它的格式。这是一个很好的学习方式。所以我认为写作要么是你喜欢做的事情，要么是你不想做的事情。我的意思是，你知道，它是……是啊。我有一个愚蠢的问题。
when you drive when you're just driving around like the driving around during the day with your kids or whatever do you constantly think in images or see images and think of filmmaking like do you is it hard to turn it off yeah it's no um it's easy to turn off oh okay never mind it's not no i don't like walk around like rain man or something like that like you know because i i always think of like whenever i'm driving around i always see like images there's like god that be such and i see like a frame around it or something i'm not a filmmaker especially when you're listening to music do you find that happening sean all the time you basically start cutting videos right yeah don't you do that change your eyes go right you know and i dork out like that how many how many wham inspired movies have you made sean in your head
当你开车时，当你白天和孩子们开车四处转悠时，无论什么，你是否不断地用图像思考或看到图像并想到电影制作，就像，很难关掉它吗？是啊，不，嗯，很容易关掉，哦，好吧，没关系，不，我不会像《雨人》那样四处走动，你知道，因为我总是想，每当我开车四处转悠时，我总是看到像图像一样的东西，就像，天哪，那会是，我看到像一个框架围绕着它，或者什么，我不是一个电影制作人，特别是在听音乐时，你发现这种情况发生了吗，肖恩，一直都在发生，你基本上开始剪辑视频了，对吧？是啊，你不是那样做吗，改变你的眼睛，你知道，我像那样书呆子气，肖恩，你在脑海里制作了多少部受威猛乐队启发的电影？
oh there's got to be like 12 i mean you know they wake me up before you go go was my holy grail You know, they're like, I was like, I can't believe there's a... Just lends itself to a real cinematic. Paul, what is it? This could be the best interview. I like, I just... You don't get to talk, Paul. I know, and this is why I like it.
哦，肯定有12部，我的意思是，你知道，他们叫醒我之前去去去，是我的圣杯，你知道，他们就像，我当时想，我不敢相信有一个……只是借给了一个真正的电影感。保罗，那是什么？这可能是最好的采访。我喜欢，我只是……你没机会说话，保罗。我知道，这就是我喜欢它的原因。
I just want to hear you guys. I have to tell you, my favorite, I heard, listen to, I don't, listen to... You haven't listened to this. I have. Of course I have. But the one joke that stuck with me forever and ever and ever was Will sing something about your father, Jason. and by father he met the security guard at the 20th century
我只是想听你们说。我必须告诉你，我最喜欢的，我听到的，听，我不，听……你没听过这个。我听过。我当然听过。但那个让我永远永远记住的笑话是，威尔唱了一些关于你父亲的事，杰森。而父亲指的是20世纪福克斯小队的保安，那听起来很对，别让杰森哭，别让杰森哭，它一直留在我的脑海里，当我在开车时，我想到了肖恩。
Fox squad that sounds about right don't make Jason cry don't make Jason cry it stuck with me where I think about that's what I think about Sean when I'm driving down the modes
偶尔我会想到一些突然出现在你脑海里的东西，你觉得天哪，那真的真的真的真的很有趣，我会，你知道，当你坐在车里开车四处转悠时，令人惊讶的是，你没有想到。
every once in a while I'll think about something pops into your head you think God that was really really really really funny and I'll you know surprising when you're in the car and you're driving around you're not thinking about
肖恩的爸爸从房子里开车离开。因为他在车里很方便。是啊。还没回来。没错。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
Sean's dad peeling away from the house. Because he was real handy in a car. Yeah. Still hasn't come back. Exactly. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
保罗，什么，请原谅我们如此愚蠢。我相信我们毁了你很多天，不得不听它。等等，我想知道，我想知道。好的，当然。是啊，肖恩，如果你有想法，就打断他们，开始说话。继续，威尔。等等，我只是想把这个处理掉。你那边的真正奥斯卡·黎凡特。
Paul, what, and forgive us for just being such fools. I'm sure we ruined many of your days having to listen to it. Wait, I want to know about, I want to know about. Okay, definitely. Yeah, just cut them off, Sean, if you get an idea, start talking. Go ahead, Will. Wait, I just want to get this out of the way. Your real Oscar Levant over there.
我想我已经看过，我很确定我已经看过你的每一部电影，并且对每一部都感到惊讶。但我只是想在忘记之前把这个处理掉。《不羁夜》，莱昂纳多真的争取过那个角色，但马克得到了吗？或者莱昂纳多因为拍《泰坦尼克号》而拒绝了，或者其中有什么真相吗？肖恩喜欢八卦，保罗。那是真的，我确实邀请了莱昂纳多出演《不羁夜》，他花了很多很多个月的时间来痛苦和争论。
I think I've seen, I'm pretty sure I've seen every single one of your films and always been amazed by each one. But I just want to get this out of the way before I forget. Boogie Nights, is it true that Leo was up for the part but Mark got it? Or Leo turned it down because he did Titanic or is there any truth to any of that? Sean loves the dirt, Paul. That is very true, is that I asked Leo to be in Boogie Nights and he spent many, many months agonizing and debating about it.
最终，我没有意识到，或者在那个漫长的决策过程进行到一半时才意识到，他有一个选择，那就是要么拍《泰坦尼克号》，要么拍《不羁夜》。
and ultimately what I didn't realize or kind of came to realize about halfway into that this sort of long decision-making process is that he had a choice to make which was to either do Titanic or to do Boogie Nights
他选择了拍《泰坦尼克号》，这当然从长远来看让他获得了巨大的全球声誉，但另一方面，我想可能，但我认为那是，我们现在对此一笑置之，但他，你知道，后悔。
and he chose to do Titanic which of course in the long run catapulted into this massive worldwide fame but on the other hand I think possibly but I think it was we laugh about it now but he you know regrets
错过了这次经历和拍摄它。但是，是啊，那是真的。是啊，没错。我一直很好奇。那会是，好吧，现在你知道了。所以。好吧，看，我永远不会知道。威尔，你的问题有那么好吗？
missing the experience and doing it. But, yeah, that's true. Yeah, that's right. I just always wondered that. It'd be, well, now you know. So. Well, see, and I would have never known. Will, was your question as good as that?
没有那么好。实际上，那非常有趣且做得很好，肖恩。恭喜。我喜欢这个想法。回到谷歌。回到谷歌，肖恩。我以为你会说，我以为你会说。
Not as good as that. Actually, that was very interesting and well done, Sean. Congrats. I like the idea. Back to Google. Back to Google, Sean. I thought you were going to say, I thought you were going to say,
直到今天，我仍然认为莱昂纳多在判断上犯了一个巨大的错误。你从来不放过它。但那是什么，不，问题其实只是简单地，你写的第一件事是什么，你说，我应该拍这个？是啊。而且你，你实际上拍的第一件事，你，用你自己的话。
and to this day, I still think Leo made a huge error in judgment. You never let it go. But what was, no, the question actually was just simply, what was that first thing that you wrote and you said, I should film this? Yeah. And that you, first thing that you actually put to film, that you, from your own words.
嗯，我确实做了，像短篇处理和拍摄清单之类的东西。但真的，有趣的是，当我16岁，快17岁时，我写了一部短片，叫《德克·迪格勒的故事》，那就是《不羁夜》的前身。它就像一个23或24页的剧本。但我用当时非常流行的格式做了它，我只有这种糟糕的摄像机，所以我意识到它看起来不会很好。
Well, I did, like, short treatments and shot lists and things like that. But really, funny enough that when I was 16, just about to turn 17, I wrote a short film that was called the Dirk Diggler story, that was what Boogie Nights became. and it was like a 23 or 24-page script. But I did it in the format that was so popular at the time, and all I had was this sort of bad video camera, so I realized it wasn't going to look good,
它看起来不会像一部电影。所以我写了这个大约23页长的东西，它是对人们回顾德克·迪格勒这个家伙的生活的采访。哦，《当前事件》在当时是一个非常受欢迎的节目。我不知道你是否记得。但他们总是会有这些，极其过度戏剧化的。
it wasn't going to look like a movie. So I wrote this thing that was about 23 pages long, and it was interviews with people looking back at the life of this guy, Dirk Diggler. Oh, a current affair was a very popular show at that time. I don't know if you remember that. But they would always have these, insanely over-dramatic
而且它太荒谬了，以至于它试图找到一种进入故事的方式，我认为这很有趣，那就是我一生中一直围绕着我的色情作品，住在我住的地方，就像我周围的东西太明显了，然后用这种格式写出来就像是一件可行的事，就像。
and it was so preposterous that it was so trying to find a way into the story that I thought was interesting which is the pornography that had surrounded me my whole life living where I lived like it was so obvious what was around me and then writing it in this format was like a doable thing like
好吧，我可以找个人，对他们进行采访，你知道，我的意思是，这是一种仍然有效的格式，你知道，但在当时，这确实是使用你手头设备进入故事的最方便和合理的方式。哇。
okay I can get somebody and do an interview with them you know I mean it's a format that's still at work you know but at the time it was really like the most convenient and plausible way into a story with the equipment that you had at hand. Wow.
你，你已经把它从，从，它是VHS吗？你知道它是8毫米，8毫米视频，所以高8，我想他们会叫它。你已经把它转移到能持续的东西上了吗，我们还能看到它吗？希望不会，希望它在某处，不，它，它被转移到了它的生命极限，它是可用的。我想它，也许它在YouTube上，我得再看看。哦，真的吗？是啊，我不确定。哇。
Did you, have you transferred that from, from, was it VHS? You know it was 8mm, 8mm video, so a high 8, I think they would call. Have you transferred it to something that'll last and are we ever going to see it? Hopefully not, hopefully it's somewhere, no, it's, it's transferred within an inch of its life, it's available. I think it, maybe it's on YouTube, I'd have to look again. Oh, really? Yeah, I'm not sure. Wow.
它并不糟糕。仍然有一些笑话是。一样的，还有一些片段，你知道，保留在《不羁夜》里，你知道，关于那个，最棒的是，我当时甚至没有意识到，在写作方面，在真正学习如何写作方面，我创造了这种，这些虚构的角色，在这个伪纪录片里，对吧？然后我意识到我必须做的是改编那个，改编这些虚构的生活，把它变成一部电影，我花了接下来的，嗯，大概10年。
It's not terrible. There's still some jokes that are. the same and things and some pieces that you know remained in boogie nights you know what was great about that was that what i didn't even realize at the time in terms of the writing in terms of really learning how to write was that i created this kind of these fictional characters in this fake documentary right and then i realized what i had to do was adapt that adapt this these fake lives into a movie and I spent the next well probably about 10 years
做那个，所以我写了一个90页的这个纪录片的版本，然后我意识到，好吧，我不想做那个，那不是这个故事的正确格式，我想把它写成一部虚构的电影，所以我做了那个，你知道，我想我花了10年时间，这就是我学习如何写作的方式，真的，就是练习讲述这个故事。
doing that so I like wrote a 90 page version of this documentary and then I realized well I don't want to do that that's not the right format for this I want to write this as a fictional film so I did that you know for 10 years I guess it was the way that I learned how to write really was practicing telling this story
以多种不同的方式，有趣的是，这似乎是许多电影制作人和作家反复出现的主题。我知道，你知道，肯尼·洛纳根过去在90年代纽约的这个剧团Back in Naked Angels里，他在周一晚上做各种场景之夜，他会做关于一个哥哥和一个妹妹的场景。
in multiple different ways it's funny that that seems to be a recurring theme with a lot of filmmakers and writers. I know, you know, Kenny Lonergan used to do at Back in Naked Angels in this theater company in New York in the 90s, he did various scene nights on Monday nights where he would do the scene about a brother and a sister
然后只是这个在纽约20多岁时有点迷失的家伙，等等，等等。它呈现了许多不同的化身，许多不同的场景，最终变成了，《这是我们的青春》，这部戏。对。我当时的女朋友，米西·耶格，在里面。
and then just this guy who was kind of lost in his 20s in New York, et cetera, et cetera. And it took on a bunch of different incarnations, a bunch of different scenes, which eventually then became, this is our youth, the play. Right. That my then girlfriend, Missy Yeager, was in,
和马克·鲁法洛和乔什·汉密尔顿一起，那后来变成了，我想，真的是《你可以信赖我》的灵感来源，你知道，但这就像这个类似的故事，类似的主题，他在至少15年里以各种方式讲述。
with Mark Ruffloh and Josh Hamilton, that then became kind of really, I think the inspiration for, you can count on me, you know, and but it was like this similar story, similar theme that he told in various ways over at least 15 years
在他最终确定那个之前。是啊。我相信你可能对此有共鸣。当然，你知道，也许有剩菜，你只是，我不知道，你的井有多深，我想你只是继续你的井，到那个程度，我的意思是，你发现它基本上是在剥洋葱，越来越深地剥开一个特定的主题，你认为这种故事是一个有趣的例子，嗯，如果是这样，那个主题是什么？是啊，但那是一个，你能写吗。
before he kind of landed on that. Yeah. I'm sure you can probably relate to that. For sure, you know, maybe there's leftovers and you're just, I don't know, how deep is your well i guess you just keep you well to that point i mean do you find that it was basically a peeling the onion further and further back on a specific theme that you thought this sort of story was a fun example of um and if so what is that theme yeah but that's a can you write
一个主题，我永远写不出主题，嗯，我的意思是，但我的意思是，你告诉我，你知道，你正在做，嗯，一个主题，比如不负责任地追求名声，比如你可以应用到那个，我从来没有像那样好的东西，我总是像，只是像，不，像，我从来没有，我有更多像事实一样的东西，比如，好吧，什么会。
a theme i can never write a theme well i mean but i mean you tell me you know you're doing um a theme of being let's say the irresponsible chase of fame let's say you could apply to that I never have anything good like that I always have like just like no like I never ever have I have more like facts like well what would
这里真的发生了什么，有些人从现实生活中窃取，就像每个故事本质上都是一样的，你知道，就像如果夸张的版本是那个走下公共汽车，你知道，带着大梦想来到好莱坞的家伙，对吧，脱掉裤子，然后下一件事你知道他是一个大。
what really happens here and some steal from real life like every story was essentially the same you know it was like if the exaggerated version was the guy who steps off the bus and you know kind of comes to Hollywood with big dreams right and takes his pants off and then the next thing you know he's a big
明星，它就是任何经典的兴衰故事，所以我总是只是跟随现实的任何步骤，我的意思是，我不知道，我从来没有，我非常害怕在事先写一个主题或有任何类似的东西，我记得在某个时候，也许需要帮助，就像，故事是什么，幸运的是，偶然发现了《雨中曲》，就像，哦，对了，它和无声电影是一样的，你知道，这是任何行业的一个过渡时期，他们从用胶片拍摄转向用视频拍摄，你知道，用这样的东西来讲述你的故事，无论什么主题都会在以后出现，好吧，是的，所以你写一个故事，你基本上只是写一个剧本，因为它是，呃，过度简化它，你，这个事件运行。
star and it was any classic rise and fall story so I'm always just sort of following any steps of reality I mean I don't know I never I get so scared of writing to a theme or having anything like that beforehand I can remember at a certain point maybe needing help like like what is the story and luckily enough coming across singing in the rain and being like oh right it's just the same thing as like silent talkies you know it's this transitional time in whatever industry they're going from shooting on film to shooting on video like use things like this to tell your story and whatever themes will will just emerge later well yes so you write a story and you basically just write a script because it's uh to oversimplify it you you this this event runs
到这个事件，这个事件，现在我们有一个结局，这是一个有趣的故事，现在你拍摄它，所有这些都运作得很好，现在你在剪辑室，你开始塑造这个，原谅这个短语，观众的体验，它开始以电影的形式呈现出来，你开始使用临时音乐或实际配乐，也许主题开始为你作为一个观众而发展，当你观看它时，试图保持观众的视角，你允许这种情况发生吗，然后这是否会影响你完成电影的方式，哦，这里，这里有一个小主题，存在于这个脆脆的故事之下，这很有趣。
to this event and this event and now we have an ending and it's a fun story and now you shoot it and all that worked out well now you're in the editing room and you start to shape this pardon the phrase experience for the audience and it starts to sort of present itself as a film and you start working with either temp music or the actual score and maybe themes start to develop for you as a viewer as you're viewing it trying to keep the the optics of a viewer do you allow that to happen and then does that inform the way you finish the film and oh here's here's a little theme that's existing underneath this crunchy story that's kind of fun.
你发现这种情况发生了吗？我发现这正是发生的事情，除了它发生得稍微早一点，你知道，一旦你，我的意思是，听着，我不瞎，你知道，当你写东西时，你也许，你在抵制主题就在你面前的想法，但仅仅因为你想尝试真实地讲述一些事情，而最终出现的东西出现了，你无法抗拒。希望你喜欢它。你正在享受正在发生的事情，但你，我认为它，你保持半只眼睛看着它，但真的。
Do you find that that happens? I find that that's exactly what happens with the exception that it does happen a little bit earlier, you know, that once you, I mean, listen, I'm not blind, you know, as you're writing something, you maybe, you're fighting off the idea that the theme is right in front of your face, but just because you want to try to tell something factually and what ends up emerging emerges and you can't fight it. Hopefully you like it. you're enjoying what's happening but you i think it and you you keep a half an eye on it but really
你发现这种情况会发生吗？我发现确实会发生，只是发生得稍微早一点。你看，我并不瞎，在写东西的时候，你可能会试图抗拒那个就在你眼前的核心主题，但因为你想尝试客观地叙述，最终浮现出来的东西就是会浮现出来，你无法抗拒。希望你喜欢它，享受正在发生的一切，我想你确实会留意它，但实际上
you keep the other eye on what are the facts what are the facts what are the facts of the story you know um why why is that because i don't know i find films that overindulge in telling me the theme are are annoying you know and boring um so but yes to your point that once you and then you get into shooting and you're seeing dailies and you're seeing stuff emerge that is really exciting or stuff that is unexpected and you either embrace it or you say perhaps this is not going in the right direction
你得时刻关注事实是什么，故事的事实是什么，你知道吗，嗯，为什么呢，因为我不知道，我发现那些过度沉溺于向我灌输主题的电影很烦人，你知道，很无聊，嗯，所以，是的，正如你所说，一旦你开始拍摄，看到样片，看到一些真正令人兴奋或意想不到的东西浮现出来，你要么接受它，要么说也许这方向不对。
but more often than not you can't stop what's coming nor should you that you have to kind of be surrender you're guiding a ship but you're also surrendering a bit to the path that's happening and you know performances kind of get bigger or smaller whatever ends up happening and then it just keeps on going
但更多时候，你无法阻止即将发生的事情，也不应该阻止，你必须顺其自然，你是在引导一艘船，但你也在某种程度上顺应正在发生的航向，你知道，表演可能会变得更夸张或更收敛，无论最终发生什么，它都会继续下去。
and you keep refining that through the editing and all that. One of the, if we can get into staying on the idea of themes, one of the themes, it seems to me, of your films is that they're very specific, visually and stylistically, each one different in its own way, but they do seem so specific in the writing. And so what is your relationship like,
你会在剪辑过程中不断完善它。如果我们继续讨论主题这个话题，在我看来，你的电影主题之一是它们非常具体，在视觉和风格上，每一部都有其独特之处，但在剧本创作上它们确实显得非常具体。那么，你的关系是怎样的，
again, going deeper into the weeds on filmmaking, but what is your relationship? like with your production designer and your and your DP leading up to when you actually shoot because it does seem like all of your films, I told you once at risk of further embarrassment to myself and to you, for instance, there will be blood. I feel like it should be just hung in MoMA and left there for people. It's an incredible piece of art in every way from the writing to the direction, to the art direction. production. What is that like for you leading up to actually rolling film in working with those
再次深入探讨电影制作的细节，你的关系是怎样的？比如你和你的美术指导以及摄影指导在正式拍摄前的关系，因为看起来你所有的电影，我曾经冒着让你我进一步尴尬的风险对你说过，例如《血色将至》。我觉得它应该被挂在现代艺术博物馆里供人欣赏。从剧本到导演，再到艺术指导和制作，它在各方面都是一件令人难以置信的艺术品。在正式开拍之前，与这些部门合作是什么样的体验？
departments? Well, it's the great joy of collaboration, particularly when you're doing it with somebody that you love and work with. Like, for instance, on that film, I had never worked with Jack Fisk, who's one of the great production designers who started his career with Terrence Malick and David Lynch. They kind of go back to their beginnings together. Anyway, I contacted to Jack Fisk and had written this script and I needed to kind of create I need a lot of help with making oil derricks
嗯，这是合作的巨大乐趣，特别是当你和你所爱并共事的人一起工作时。例如，在那部电影中，我从未与杰克·菲斯克合作过，他是伟大的美术指导之一，他的职业生涯始于泰伦斯·马利克和大卫·林奇。他们从职业生涯之初就一直在一起。总之，我联系了杰克·菲斯克，我写了这个剧本，我需要创造，我在制作油井架方面需要很多帮助，
and the recreation of an early California town and there was only one person that helped do that so it started a great collaboration Jack Fisk was you know we were kind of trying to learn how to get oil out of the ground and really trying to be really
以及重建一个早期的加州小镇，只有一个人能帮我做到这一点，所以这开启了一段伟大的合作，杰克·菲斯克，你知道，我们当时试图学习如何从地下开采石油，并真正努力地去进行研究，他说了一句最棒的话，他说，你知道，我发现如果我们能找到一本关于这个的儿童读物，这真的比试图通过所有这些厚厚的书来理解如何操作要好得多。这是一个伟大的教训，就像，是的，先找那本儿童读物，
you know do our research and he said the greatest thing he's like you know I found that if we can just get a children's book about this, it's really better than trying to really understand how to do it with all these kind of books that are this thick. And it was one of these great lessons and like, yeah, get the children's book
不要，你知道，因为里面会有图画，会很简单。当时我就想，哇，杰克·菲斯克先找儿童读物。好吧，这真是个好建议。但我们一起去勘景并寻找拍摄这部电影的地方，这是一种难以置信的快乐。
first and don't be, you know, because it'll have drawings, it'll be simple. And it was like, wow, Jack Fis gets the children's book first. All right, that's really good advice. But we had an incredible joy of going to scout locations together and find a place to make
我从他那里学到了一个不可思议的技巧，我至今仍在努力实践，那就是，如果你能找到一个所有东西都靠得很近的拍摄地点，你就会拥有更多的自由。我的意思是，如果你在这里拍了一个场景，几天后你再看，觉得那是我们拍过的最烂的场景，我们真的应该重拍，那么你就可以去重拍。你知道，你创造了自己的积压，你创造了自己的宇宙，并尽可能多地尝试不要移动太多，而是要拥有各种不同的外观和正在发生的事情。
this film. And I learned from him one incredible trick that I still try to make true is that the more you can have a location where everything is close together the more freedom you have here's what I mean about that is that if you shoot a scene you know over here and you see it a few days later you think that's the worst scene that we've ever done we should really try to do it again is that you can go do it again you know you kind of create your own You create your own backlog, you create your own universe and try as much as you possibly can to not move too much, but to have a variety of different looks and things happening.
所以，我不知道，我忘了你刚才的问题是什么了。大概是关于合作。嗯，简单有时会产生一些最复杂和最精致的结果，也许吧。当然，那是我的角色。与为那部电影作曲的强尼·格林伍德有类似的合作过程吗？我相信那是他第一次为电影作曲，也是你们第一次合作？
So that, I don't know, I'm lost in whatever your question was. It was kind of like the collaboration. Well, the simplicity sometimes yields some of the most complex and sophisticated results, perhaps. Sure, that's my role. Was there a similar process with Johnny Greenwood who did the, for Tracy was the composer on that film. I believe it was the first time he'd composed music for a film and the first time you guys worked together?
是的，是的。他为管弦乐队写了一段音乐，因为他已经非常精通如何为弦乐器写作。并不是说，别让他骗了你。我的意思是，我知道他是……但显然，他的配乐令人难以置信，电影中的其他一切也是如此。
Yeah, yeah. There was a piece of music that he had written for orchestra because he was already well-versed in how to write for string instruments. It wasn't like, don't let him fool you. I mean, I know he's... But obviously, his score was incredible, as was everything else in the film.
这真的很不可思议，这是一个机会……你知道，看，我想……不，没有什么疯狂奇怪的配乐之类的东西。他确实会对乐器做一些有趣的事情，他会把管弦乐队的某些部分调低音，而让其他部分保持标准音。所以他有能力让它听起来非常熟悉。你听到的是弦乐器，但听起来又有一种超脱感，让你无法准确判断它是什么。所以他在那方面很天才，但那种东西。
It is really incredible, and it's an opportunity... You know, look, I think... No, there was no kind of crazy weird instrumentation or something like that. He does do funny things with instruments where he'll detune certain pieces of the orchestra and keep others in tune. And so he has the ability to make it sound very familiar. You're hearing string instruments, but that sounds just out of body enough that you can't quite place it. So he's brilliant like that, but that sort of stuff.
这，你知道，这很好，这是一种技巧，但他写出了优美的音乐来衬托电影，它们相辅相成，这是一段美好合作的开始。你在写作时会有意识地考虑到这一点吗，比如空间感，或者你在写作时会听一些东西吗？是的，当然。我的意思是，我有很多……
It's, you know, it's nice, it's trickery, but he writes beautiful music that complements the film and they go hand in hand and it was the beginning of a beautiful collaboration. Do you consciously keep that in mind when you're writing, like spaces or do you listen to stuff when you write? Yeah, for sure. I mean, I had all kinds of...
我当时听的东西反正也是他喜欢的。是潘德列茨基还是舒伯特，或者，你知道，甚至是他为英国广播公司管弦乐团写的那首曲子？所以这已经在某种程度上影响了我的思路。去找他说，
The stuff that I was listening to was stuff that he likes anyway. Was it Pendericki or Schubert or, you know, even the piece that he had written for the BPC orchestra? So that was already kind of informing where my head was at. And it was nice to go to him and say,
就像，你知道，这部电影本身就适合那种广阔的开放空间，而且是一个巨大的机会，可以用音乐来填补长时间的沉默，这些音乐既可以震耳欲聋，也可以在下面暗流涌动。所以对他来说，这是一个非常好的入行机会。我喜欢这个。你开车去接孩子放学或者其他什么的时候会放什么音乐？比如，你喜欢什么乐队？是的，你孩子上车时你必须关掉立体声换成什么音乐？嗯，他们已经听腻了那张Smile唱片，他们听得够多了。
like, you know, the movie lends itself, too, to just, like, wide open spaces and, like, a huge opportunity to fill long gaps of silence with music that can either be gigantically loud or even just simmering underneath. So it was quite a good entrance into the game for him. I love that. What's the music that you put on when you go, like, pick up the kids from school or whatever? Like, what are you, what are your bands? Yeah, what's the music you have to take off the stereo when your kids get in and put on uh well they're already sick of that smile record they've been hearing that enough yeah
是的，他们就像是，够了，够了，够了。好吧，来吧，珍珠现在在听什么？珍珠在听，嗯，你知道她在听什么，是任何东西，我不知道是哪位艺术家的，但是，嗯，我们现在对这部电影《世界上最糟糕的人》有点着迷。是的，我不知道你们看过没有，我发了预告片，看起来很棒。哦，这电影简直太神奇了。而且它有很棒的原声带。所以我们一直在听原声带里的各种歌曲，从哈里·尼尔森到托德·朗德格伦，
yeah they're like they're like enough with that enough enough enough so well come on what's pearl listening to right now pearl is listening to well you know what she's listening to is anything and i don't know in any of the many of the artists but um we just we're kind of obsessed right now with this film the worst person in the world yeah i don't know if you guys have seen it i send the trailer it looks great Oh, it's fucking magical, this film. And it's got this great soundtrack. So we've just kind of been listening to all this variety of songs on that soundtrack, which is everything from like Harry Nelson and Todd Rungering
再到很多我这辈子都没听过的新东西，你知道。我想问你一些关于流媒体与广泛发行，以及我们所处的现状和商业模式的问题。我和一个朋友谈过这个。我们谈到，例如《西区故事》或《甘草披萨》或者现在市面上任何精彩的电影，
to a lot of new stuff that I've never heard in my life, you know. I want to ask you something about, you know, streaming versus wide release and where we're at and the business of that. And I was having this conversation with a friend. And we were talking about how, for example, West Side Story, or licorice pizza or whatever it is that's out there that's fantastic right now
如果进行非常长期的广泛发行会怎样？还会有人看这些东西吗？我们是否真的已经到了只想在家里看东西的地步？但作为电影制作人，我想你一定希望它能在银幕上被看到，因为这种电影类型，
how that would have fared with a really long, wide release run would anybody see these things? Are we really truly at the point where we just want to see stuff in our homes but to the filmmaker I imagine you want it to be seen on that big screen because of the genre of filmmaking
对吧？因为这种东西本身就适合那样，所以你对此有什么看法？嗯，是的，我的意思是，我不知道，我有点，我不知道，我的意思是，我喜欢一切，你知道。我的意思是，我真的喜欢。我听起来像丹尼尔·普莱恩维尤，就像，我喜欢各种宗教。它们都他妈的，你知道，我不会，我不会，我不会去管你。
right? Because of the thing that lends itself to that so what are your thoughts about that? Well yeah I mean I, I don't know, I kind of, I don't know, I mean, I like everything, you know. I mean, I really do. I sound like Daniel Plainview is like, I like all kinds of religions. They're all fucking, you know, I'm not going to, like, I'm not going to, like, I'm not going to get in your back.
没错。等等，等等，但当你拍电影时，你脑子里的想法难道不是，我迫不及待想在大银幕上看到它吗？是的。对。绝对是。绝对是。所以在这个行业的商业运作中，似乎越来越少，
Exactly. Wait, wait, but when you make a movie, isn't the idea in your head, I can't wait to see this on the big screen. Yes. Right. Absolutely. Absolutely. And so with the, with the business of this business, it just seems to be less and less that
如果它不是那些大型超级英雄电影之一，它就会……好吧，听着，这完全正确，我的意思是，就这一点而言，嗯，这个国家可能只有30家影院看起来和听起来都很棒，其余的都是垃圾。我很抱歉，但事实就是这样，这就是可悲的真相，我可以理解为什么每个人都说，去你的，我待在家里。你知道，你想要我付钱请保姆，付停车费，然后进去看这些垃圾，而且是在一个你们甚至都没有，我不知道，在某种程度上很难辩护。
if it's not one of these big superhero movies it's gonna well listen that's exactly right i mean to that point is um there's probably you know 30 theaters in this country where it would look great and sound great and the rest are fiff i'm sorry but it's like you know it's and that's the sad truth of it is that i can understand why everybody says like oh piss off i'm staying at home you know what you want me to pay for a babysitter and pay for parking and come in and look at this shit and look at it on a fucking screen that you guys haven't even you know i don't know it's hard to defend at a certain point yeah yeah but i'm sure that if god forbid the the business became a place where it's only event movies in in in theaters and the only place that you can expect your film to
是的，是的，但我敢肯定，如果天哪，这个行业变成了一个只有活动电影才能在影院上映的地方，而你唯一能指望你的电影被看到的地方就是家里，因为它不是什么大特效电影之类的，你宁愿人们看电影，能够制作电影并让他们在家里看，也不愿根本不拍电影。
be seen is at home based on it's not a big effects thing or whatever you'd you'd much rather people see a film, be able to make films and have them see it at home, then make no films at all. Right, but I don't know. I think that's kind of bullshit too, because the reason why is when all these theaters were opening up, again, you know, you have these huge, gigantic
对，但我不知道。我觉得那也是胡扯，因为原因在于，当所有这些影院开业时，你知道，你有这些巨大的、庞大的25厅影院之类的东西，每个人都在哭喊，哦，它们是空的。就像，好吧，你他妈以为会发生什么？但如果你去任何一家伟大的影院，比如在洛杉矶或纽约，播放特色节目的影院，它们都挤满了人。他们都出现了。
25 plexes and stuff like that, and everybody was crying, oh, they're empty. It was like, well, what did you fucking think was going to happen? But if you go to any of the great theaters, let's say, in Los Angeles or New York, that are playing specialty programming, they're packed with people. They're all turning out.
他们是电影爱好者，你知道那些会出来支持这件事的人。因为有一个拥有400个座位的影院，他们可以填满它，他们可以每天放映两场或三场，
They're film lovers, the people that you know are going to come out and turn out for this thing. And because there's one theater with 400 seats that they can fill and they can do two shows a day or three shows a day
人们仍然会出现。就像每个人都在挠头，没人回来看电影了。就像，好吧，他们不会回到我们建造的这些奇怪、可怕的金字塔里。但保罗，我想你所说的，我不想替你说话，但有一点，
and people will still turn up. It's like everyone's scratching their head no one's coming back for the movies. It's like, well, they're not coming back to these weird, horrible pyramids that we've built. But Paul, I think that what you're saying, and I don't want to put words in your mouth, but is there is a little bit of,
嗯，当然他们不会回来，因为看看你放进影院的东西就是问题的一部分，A，我可以这么说，我知道因为你的地位和你制作的电影，你很难这么说，你可能不想成为那个说这种话的人，但你制作了你想要的那些真正令人难以置信的电影，同时，你并没有以许多其他电影制作人似乎那样的方式寻求对他人的认可。这从来不是关于你自己的，你知道，提升你的个人名声。所以我的问题是，
well, of course they're not going to come back because look what you're putting in the theaters is part of the problem, A, and I can say that, and I know it's hard for you to say because of your position in the films that you make, and you probably don't want to be that guy who says that, but you make the kind of films that you want that are really incredible films, and at the same time, you don't seek out recognition for yourself in a way that a lot of other filmmakers seem to do. It's never about your own sort of, you know, increasing your personal fame. So my question to you is, how much of that,
你对演艺圈有多少了解，或者你是否处于你制作电影的泡沫中？不，我有了解，然后我又没有。我进进出出，因为我热爱，热爱电影的一部分，就像我一样，电影的历史和我，你知道，我对这项工作的痴迷，它一直伴随着我，是我一生所做的事情，
are you aware of show business, in fact, or are you kind of in your bubble of making the films that you make? No, I do, and then I don't. I slip in and out of it because I love, part of loving movies as much as I do, the history of movies and my, you know, my obsession with this work, which has been with me forever, is what I've made of my life,
它确实涉及到对它如何运作的着迷，你知道，就像我们之前谈到的，我在《雨中曲》里，你知道，那是一个精彩的故事，当电影行业从有声电影转变时发生了什么，所以我不断尝试关注这一点，或者尝试理解它，或者多年来在这个行业里有足够多的朋友，我可以打电话问，你知道，这意味着什么？当这部电影表现良好时，这意味着什么？或者这里会发生什么？
it does involve being fascinated with the way that it moves, you know, like we were talking about, before I was singing in the rain, you know, that's a fantastic story, the way that, what happened to the movie business when it changed from talkies to, so I constantly try to keep an eye on that or try to understand it or have enough friends in this business from over the years that I can call up and ask, you know, what does this mean? What does this mean when this film is doing well? Or what is going to happen here?
你看到了什么趋势，衡量这些东西很好。我热爱这个行业，我太热爱电影了，以至于我真的有兴趣看到它生存下去，但更多时候，我一天的工作量更多地变成了关于电影保护，你知道，嗯，以及电影历史，并试图让那些东西保持活力，因为，嗯，然后只是观察正在发生的事情并做出反应，我想，但我不知道，嗯，你多久与昆汀·塔伦蒂诺在这些努力上合作一次，因为我知道他对电影历史有真正的热情，并向人们介绍我可能没看过的东西。他在这方面很棒，但他在这方面很了不起，是最好的之一，但他确实
what ties do you see turning and it's nice to gauge that stuff i i love this business and i love i love movies so much that i have a real interest in seeing it survive but more often than not the the volume of my day becomes more about film preservation you know um and and film history and trying to keep that stuff alive because um and then just sort of looking to see what's happening and reacting i suppose but i don't know um how often do you collaborate with with quentin tarentino on those efforts, because I know he's got a real passion for the history of cinema and turning people on to stuff that perhaps I haven't seen. He's great about all that, but he's amazing about it, one of the best, but he also really
走在自己的轨道上，你知道，因为他，我合作最多的人是斯科塞斯，因为他有电影基金会。他，从70年代，从70年代末，80年代初开始，走访了城里的每一家制片厂，说，看，这是最悲惨的时候，当他们存在以来制作的产品真的在褪色和死亡，没有得到照顾。你必须，这只是在家庭娱乐VHS出现的边缘。
runs in his own lane, you know, because he, the person who I collaborate the most with that is Scorsese because he has the film foundation. He, since the 70s, since the late 70s, early 80s, went around to every studio in town. and said, look, this is when it was really tragic, when the products they had made since their existence were really fading away and dying and weren't being taken care of. You have to, this is sort of just on the cusp of VHS
所以他在电影基金会成立之初就真的在那里说，这是这个国家所能提供的最大的文化历史事物，我们必须保护它，我们必须照顾它。我们必须投入金钱和时间，
coming around in home entertainment. So he was really out there at the very beginning with the Film Foundation saying, this is the biggest cultural historical thing that this country has to offer and we have to preserve it and we have to take care of it. We have to invest money and time
以及人力来弄清楚这一点。所以成为他电影基金会的一部分是我一生中最大的荣誉之一。那太棒了。我们马上回来。好吧，回到节目。保罗，我知道你是个大喜剧迷，你显然和桑德勒合作过。
and manpower into figuring this out. So being a part of his film foundation has been one of the great honors in my life. That's great. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Paul, I know you're a big comedy fan and you've obviously collaborated with Sandler.
并且娶了全好莱坞最有趣的女人。或者世界上。也许我们可以直接说世界上。为了特蕾西。玛雅·鲁道夫，特蕾西。玛雅是我们最早的嘉宾之一，我对她说，你是最早的嘉宾之一。
And married the funniest woman in Hollywood. Or in the world. Maybe we can just say the world. For Tracy. Maya Rudolph, Tracy. Maya was one of our first guests I said that to her I said you were one of the first guests
她说不，我想你是。她就像是前两三个之一，对吧？玛雅是那种人，如你所知。你给她分了一块蛋糕吗？不，不，我应该给的。不过我们给她寄了一个蛋糕。是的，她应该得到的，她是那种人。
She was like no I was I think you were She was like one of the first two or three right Maya is one of those people as you know Did you give her a piece of the pie? No no I should have We sent her a cake though Yeah She should have got that she is one of those people
任何时候你在做任何有趣的事情，你都会想，那会很棒，然后你可以让玛雅来盖个章。是的，你知道，因为她太，你们是怎么认识的？在哪里？
That anytime you're doing anything funny you go So then it would be great And then you could get Maya Just to stamp it Yeah you know Because she's so just How did you guys meet Where did that
正如威尔所说，你长期以来一直是喜剧的超级粉丝。你只是对她着迷，然后说，你愿意和我共进晚餐吗？就是那样。是的，很简单，对吧？或者你向左滑还是向右滑？我不知道这有什么伤害。看，保罗？这不容易，对吧？
As Will was saying, you've been a huge fan of comedy for a long time. Did you just fan out on her and say, will you have dinner with me? It was just like that. Yeah, it's simple, right? Or did you swipe left or right? I don't know how it hurts. See, Paul? It's not easy, is it?
在贝特曼面前咬住舌头并不容易。我知道他想伤害我。你知道，这很有趣。我不确定那是什么，我想，这就像，任何像，你知道，我不知道，有像，你知道，想成为摇滚明星的演员，或者，你知道，想成为演员的音乐家，就像制作严肃电影的人真的只是喜欢喜剧，你知道？就像，我拍了这些电影，我以为它们很有趣，但人们说，就像，你知道，不是。你拍得非常有趣。嗯，我想，我想，真的，你从不要求笑声，这就是让它如此该死地有趣的原因。
It's not easy to bite your tongue with Bateman. He wants to hurt me, I know. You know, it's funny. I'm not sure what it is, that it's, I guess it's like, Anything like, you know, I don't know, there's like, you know, actors that wanted to be rock stars or, you know, musicians wanted to be actors, like people that making serious films really just like, the one thing they really loved was comedies, you know? Like, I had made these films, I thought that they were funny, but people were saying, like, you know, it's not. You make really funny. Well, I think, I think, really, you never ask for a laugh, and that's what makes it so goddamn funny.
没有眨眼。这很棒。抱歉，谢谢，因为我，是的，因为我观看的一切，或者在我日常生活中，就像我只是狼吞虎咽地吸收那些东西，我在玛雅开始SNL时遇到了她，嗯，嗯，是的，那意味着什么，你们是怎么认识的？嗯，你知道有趣的是，她在家里也让你笑吗，保罗？嗯，她确实让我们笑。她一定是个在家里很爱开玩笑的人。有人曾经对我说，这让我想起，我想我曾经说过一次，
There's no winking. It's great. sorry thank you because i yeah because everything everything that that i watched or in my daily kind of existence was just like i just devoured that stuff and i met my when she'd started SNL um um and yeah what what was that meaning how did you guys meet well you know the funny thing is is that she make you laugh at home too call uh she sure makes us laugh She just must be a cut-up at home Somebody once said to me That reminds me, I think I told this once
有人对我说，当艾米和我结婚时，他们说，和美国最有趣的人结婚是什么感觉？我说，你得去问我妻子。但我喜欢那个。你觉得有趣的人，
Somebody said to me When Amy and I were married They said, what's it like being married To the funniest person in America And I said, you'd have to ask my wife But I love that Do you find that funny people
在家里通常都很严肃吗？是的。嗯哼。没什么好笑的。但我确实想知道。你们是怎么认识的，保罗？你怎么在迈阿密？
Are generally pretty serious When they're at home? Yes. Uh-huh. Nothing funny about it. But I do want to know that. How did you meet, Paul? How did you in Miami?
我真的想知道。在SNL，对吧？在SNL，那是威尔·法瑞尔和莫莉·香农的时代，我遇到了莫莉·香农。她说，你知道，你可以来看看我们是怎么做这个的。当时我正在写《私恋失调》，我对他（桑德勒）在那里的时光很着迷。所以我接受了那个邀请，去看看，然后在幕后观看，你知道。
I really do want to. At SNL, right? At SNL, that was the time with Will Ferrell and Molly Shannon, and I had met Molly Shannon. And she said, you know, you could come and you can see how we do this. And at the time I was writing Punch Drunk Love and I was obsessed with that time that Sandler had been there. So I accepted that offer to come and look and then watch, you know, behind the scenes.
然后莫莉说，好吧，你知道你可以导演一个短片，所以我导演了一个有她出演的短片，并见证了这一切的内部运作，当时我也开始了解桑德勒，并问他那里的时光，我正准备和他一起制作《私恋失调》。
and then Molly said well you know you can direct a short so I directed a short with her in it and just got to kind of witness the inner workings of this whole thing and at that time I was also getting to know Sandler and asking him about his time there I was getting ready to make punch drunk love with him
当我准备离开我在那里的那一周时，我的头在旋转，我想，好吧，那太棒了，但我不想再做一次了，因为那太多了，那是另一种工作节奏，我很高兴我做了，但这已经足够了。
and as I was getting ready to leave after my week there my head was spinning I was like well that was great but I don't want to fucking do that again because it was so much it was a different pace of work and I was thrilled to have done it but that was enough of a taste.
他们说有人递给我一张纸条之类的东西，我看了看，上面的信息是下周有一个新的演员要开始工作，她的名字叫玛雅·鲁道夫，我记得在纸上看到她的名字，如果你有过这种感觉，但你第一次看到某样东西，
They said there was a piece of paper that somebody had put in my hands or something like that and I looked at it and the information was on it that there was a new cast member starting next week and her name was Maya Rudolph and I can remember seeing her name on that piece of paper if you've had any feeling like this but you see something for the first time
你意识到我的生活刚刚改变了。我不知道怎么回事。我不知道为什么。我不知道刚才发生了什么。所以……哇。但是，你知道，很快，你就继续前进了。你只是，无论如何，你有别的事情要做。
and you realize that my life has just changed. I don't know how. I don't know why. I don't know what just happened. And so... Wow. But, you know, quickly, you kind of move on. You just, whatever, you have something else to do.
你必须吃掉它，你知道。但回想起来，我，显然，那种冲动，那种，那种闪耀的感觉，如果我们要开放的话，任何人都可能发生，发生了。是的。所以我四处游荡，然后我在电视上看到了她。我看到了她在做什么，我和节目中的几个人保持着联系，
You have to eat it, you know. But looking back, I, obviously, that impulse, whatever that kind of, that shining kind of feeling that can happen to any of us, if we're open to it, happened. Yeah. And so I roamed around, and then I saw her on television. and I saw what she was doing and I had stayed in touch with a few people from the show
天哪，这个人太棒了，我在回来的路上停下来看，我们在节目中见面了，然后我不得不去伦敦，去制作《私恋失调》，然后我到了伦敦，我说，嗯，感觉不对劲，
and my God this one's amazing and I'm on my way back through I stopped to watch and we met at the show and then I had to go on to London and I to work on Punch Dr. Glove and then I got to London and I said well something didn't feel right
我就回到了纽约。哇。我回来了，然后那真是他妈的美妙，伙计。真的。所以你回到纽约是因为你觉得被她吸引了，
and I just came back to New York wow and I came back and then that's fucking beautiful man. For real. So you come back to New York because you felt drawn back to her
然后打电话给她说，我们出去吧？是的。不，我喜欢那个。我非常想在里面开个玩笑，但我喜欢那个故事。他融化了我冰冷的心。肖恩也有那种感觉，那种看到某样东西被写下来的同样感觉，
and called her and said, let's go out? Yeah. No, I love that. I wanted to make a joke in there so badly, but I love that story. He's melted my cold heart. Sean had that feeling, that same feeling of seeing something written
当有人推销一张在拐角处开业的新Vons超市的传单时。哦，我以为你是说当他开车经过一家新的Chin Chin餐厅时，他不得不折返，他知道他的生活。从那以后我就没离开过。杰森也有同样的感觉，
when somebody pushed a flyer for a new vons that was opening around the corner. Oh, I thought you were saying when he drove by a new chin chin and he had to double back and he knew his life. And I haven't left since. Jason felt the same way
当他发现好莱坞的截止日期有一个应用程序时。但是，但是，但是，那真是，那真是他妈的不可思议，伙计。我喜欢那个。玛雅也提醒我，保罗，
when he found out the deadline in Hollywood had an app. But, but, but, that is, that's fucking incredible, man. I love that. Maya reminds me, too, Paul,
你和我出生在同一天，同一年。每年她都提醒我。我一直都在想。我们，我们是一样的，肖恩。6月26日，1970年6月26日。你们两个家伙是。是的，但你出生在哪个城市？
that you and I born the same day, same year. Every year she reminds me. I think of it all the time. We're, we're one in the same, Sean. June 26th, June 26th, 1970. You two guys are. Yeah, but what city were you born in?
芝加哥，常青公园。我出生在医院。我不带公园，但我只说芝加哥。是的。哇。你呢？我出生在这里，在洛杉矶，在现在是科学教中心的地方，我想那是圣约翰医院？不，那是黎巴嫩雪松医院。
Chicago, Evergreen Park. I was born in the hospital. I don't bring a park, but I just say Chicago. Yeah. Wow. You? I was born here in Los Angeles at what is now the Scientology Center, which was St. John's, I guess it was? No, it was Cedars of Lebanon.
它叫那个名字。在富兰克林街上？不，不，在那边的远东。就在日落大道和好莱坞大道交汇的地方，那个大楼。几乎靠近普罗斯佩克特。是的，就在拐角处。那栋楼从天主教变成了科学教？没错。
It was called. On Franklin? No, no, the far east of that. Right there where Sunset and Hollywood meet, that big, they blew building. Almost near Prospect. Yeah, right around the corner. It went from Catholic to Scientology at that building? That's right.
那太神奇了。嘿，你知道，你提到了桑德勒。你比任何人都早看到亚当身上的什么特质？嗯，我一直喜欢亚当生气的时候。你知道，他暴力的一面会显露出来。我想我记得那个故事，有一个小品叫《丹尼斯秀》，他在和他的前女友丹尼斯说话，
That's amazing. Hey, you know, you mentioned Sandler. What was it you saw in Adam earlier than anybody else did? Well, I always liked it when Adam would get angry. You know, the violent part of him would come out. And it was like, and I guess I saw the story that I remember, there was a sketch called The Denise Show where he's talking to his ex-girlfriend, Denise,
由香农·达里扮演。这是一个足够有趣的设定，他一直试图挽回她，但有一个时刻他开始尖叫，我想他爸爸打来电话，在免提上，他开始对他父亲尖叫，有一个时刻，桑德勒，
who's played by Shannon Darry. and it's a funny enough premise and he keeps trying to woo her back but there's a moment when he starts screaming I think his dad calls up and is on the speakerphone and he starts screaming at his father and there was a moment where Sandler
他投入得太深了，以至于他眼白变成了黑色，就像，我能感觉到，表演中有一种愤怒和投入的程度，我说，那是不一样的。他不仅仅是在尖叫，表现得像，他可能在这一切之下完全是精神病，我喜欢它。
he's so invested in it that the whites of his eyes turned black and it's like and I could just there was a level of anger and commitment to this performance, I said, that is something else. That he's not just screaming and being like, he potentially is completely psychotic underneath all of it, and I loved it.
那太棒了，我喜欢那个。是的，而且，你知道，他有一种很棒的身体语言，我，是的，喜欢和亚当一起工作。你有没有任何渴望，特别是现在有这么多这种所谓的限定剧？这是否吸引你，
That's great, I love that. Yeah, and it was, you know, he had a great physical way about him, and I, yeah, loved working with Adam. Do you ever have any desire to, especially now that there makes so many of these sort of limited series? Does that ever appeal to you
能够讲述……400页的剧本？在更长的时间里……是的。好吧。我不知道。我在这里说话要小心。因为我只有……
the idea of being able to tell... 400-page script? Over a longer... Yeah. Okay. I don't know. I want to be careful what I say here. Because I've only...
在过去几周里，我对似乎是一个真正不幸的事件转折变得有点全神贯注，那就是80分钟的故事被变成了，比如，九集，你知道，那种……这似乎成了当天的呼声。就像，这就是我们正在做的。而事实上，你知道，就像去你的。
In the past couple weeks have become a little bit preoccupied with what seems to be a real unfortunate turn of events, which is 80-minute stories being turned into, like, nine-part, you know, things that... It just seems to be the kind of the call of the day. Like, this is what we're doing. when in fact, you know, it's like piss off.
我不，这被拉得太长了，你知道。我的意思是，我昨晚在看《开罗紫玫瑰》，大约92分钟，绝对完美，而且塞满了故事。你知道，这很有趣，因为人们总是这么说，他们说，你看过某某吗，你看过新剧某某吗？他们说，我试着看，不，你得等到第九集。是的，等到第三集，对吧？
I don't, this is stretched out way too much, you know. I mean, I was watching the Purple Rose of Cairo last night, which is about 92 minutes and absolutely perfect, and it's packed so much story. You know, it's so interesting because people say that all the time, they're like, did you see so-and-so, did you see the new series blank or whatever? And they're like, I try to get into, no, you got to wait nine episodes in. Yeah, just wait till the third one, right?
第三集对吧，我知道，疯了。第一集之后能好看吗？是的，不，所以我只是最近才真正感觉到这一点，当我，我没有立足之地，因为我还没有真正，我不想在这里听起来像个混蛋，但我没看过多少，因为我的观看总是这样，如果我有机会看电视，我他妈最终是在看老电影，你知道，这只是我的重力把我拉向那个方向，用我一天中有的时间。
third one right i know insane can it be good after the first one yeah no so i but i only have been really feeling this lately when i'm and i i don't have a leg to stand on because i haven't really i don't want to sound like an asshole here but i haven't seen much of it because my viewing always goes like if i have opportunity to watch tv i fucking end up i'm watching old movies you know it's just sort of like my gravity pulls me that way with the time that I have in the day.
但是，你知道，有时你有一个非常大的故事，比如大规模的故事，任何史诗故事。那些都很棒。过去有这种机会，他们会有像《战争风云》或者，你知道，《根》或者这些巨大的迷你剧。就像，好吧，那太棒了。那本身就是一种艺术品。但现在我感觉到这种慢动作的转变，
But, you know, sometimes you have a story that's very large, like a large-scale story, any kind of epic stories. And those are great. And there used to be this opportunity they would have like the winds of war or, you know, roots or these huge mini-series. It was like, okay, that's fantastic. That used to be a kind of work of art in and of itself. But now I feel this kind of slow-motion turn
朝着故事被拉长。我想太多了。我想在它之下，我有一种恐惧，即在最好两小时内，希望90分钟内讲述一个故事的痛苦而困难的挑战，将开始丢失，因为我认为这是一种非常有价值的叙事，你知道，那种结构很棒。是的。我不想看到它丢失。存在着我们正在重新连接我们如何欣赏这些东西的风险。
towards stories stretched out. Too much, I think. I guess underneath it, I have a fear that the painfully difficult challenge of telling a story in preferably under two hours, hopefully 90 minutes, will start to get lost, because I think it's a very, very valuable storytelling, you know, that structure is great. Yeah. I don't want to see that get lost. There is the risk that we rewiring how we appreciate those things.
我看了那个，嗯，内维尔·张伯伦的故事，嗯，你知道，与希特勒签署慕尼黑协定，关于苏台德地区，等等，等等，试图避免战争。这只是那天晚上放松一下。只是为了放松。是的。它在Tubi上，我想它在Tubi上。有趣的是，他们讲述了这个非常简单的故事，只是那个时代和那两个试图改变进程的人的那个非常具体的故事的快照，
And I watched that, um, the story of Neville Chamberlain, uh, you know, signing the Munich agreement with Hitler over the Sudeten land, et cetera, et cetera, trying to avoid war. This was just to unwind the other night. Just to unwind. Yeah. It was on tuby, I think it was on tubing. And what was interesting was, was they was telling this really simple story that was just a snapshot of that time and of that very specific story in these two guys who tried to, uh, alter the course of
我看到一半时意识到，我想，正如你所说，我很惊讶他们没有试图把它拉长，而且他们实际上制作了这部电影，这在我看的时候变得非常令人惊讶，因为我们已经变得如此习惯于，我们的大脑被连接到，你知道，太好了，现在会有12集这个了。对。
and I realized halfway through, I thought, to your point, was like, I'm surprised that they didn't try to stretch it out and that they'd actually made this film became quite surprising to me while I was watching it because we've become so accustomed to, and our brains are wired to, you know, great, there's going to be 12 episodes of this now. Right.
是的。让我们谈谈相反的情况。预告片。我想你喜欢预告片。是的。基于你的预告片是多么令人难以置信。而且我想你自己剪辑它们？我喜欢预告片。
Yeah. Let's talk about the opposite. Trailers. I think you love trailers. Yeah. Based on how incredible your trailers are. and I think you cut them yourself? I love trailers.
预告片有它们自己的小艺术形式。对。我过去剪辑过它们，或者与人合作过。我们做的最后一个不是我剪的。是一个叫乔尔的人剪的，他有一家叫Aspect Ration的公司。那是那些伟大的时刻之一，我只是把电影交给他，说，
Trailers are their own little art form. Right. I have cut them in the past or collaborated with people. The last one that we did was not cut by me. It was cut by a guy named Joel, who's got a company called Aspect Ration. And it was one of those great moments where I just handed the film over and said,
你能做点什么吗？它立刻就太完美了，以至于我们什么都没说。我们只是说，就是这样，你知道。这太棒了。那是一种非常有趣的感受。但是的，我总是，那对我来说是去电影院坐着坐着的乐趣之一。我想世界上大概有两种人，
can you do something? And it was so perfect right away that we didn't say anything. We just said, that's it, you know. It was great. And that was a really fun feeling. But yeah, I always, that was one of the joys to me of going to sit in a movie theater. I guess there's people, there's probably two types of people in the world,
喜欢坐下来看预告片的人，然后是喜欢看电影片尾字幕的人，你知道。喜欢看片尾字幕的人和不喜欢看片尾字幕的人。我喜欢看片尾字幕。是的。你曾经在书里描述过有四个孩子，我认为是最好的方式。我想我在我们有玛雅的时候提到过这个，那就是，我会把它混在一起，你纠正我，有四个孩子就像在房子里有四堆舒适的火在燃烧，
people that like to sit down and watch trailers and then people that like to watch the credits of movies, you know. People like to watch credits and people that don't like to watch the credits. I like to watch the credits. Yeah. You once described having four kids in the book, best way I thought possible. I think I mentioned this when we had my on, which was, and I'll mash this up, you correct me, that having four kids is like having four cozy fires burning in the
只是听到他们跑来跑去，听起来你和我一样是个宅男。你是怎么设法工作得这么努力，同时又是一个不可思议的父亲，不是一个，不是两个，不是三个，而是四个孩子？嗯，我希望如此。我的意思是，时间会证明一切。是的，这非常危险。我记得露西尔·鲍尔在60年代中期做这些电台采访时有一些很棒的片段。
house, just hearing them run around, and it sounds like you're as much of a homebody as I am. How do you manage to work as hard as you do and still be an incredible father to not one, not two, not three, but four kids? Well, I hope so. I mean, time will tell. Yeah, this is very dangerous. I remember there's these great episodes where Lucille Ball doing these radio interviews from the mid-60s.
我不知道你有没有听过那些。它们在Sirius XM上播了一段时间，你听到所有这些人谈论他们作为父母的优势，然后你就会意识到，你知道，时间确实证明了完全不同，你知道，他们听到这些人谈论。你知道，我们确实在周末花时间，
I don't know if you've heard those. They were on Sirius XM for a little while, and you hear all these people talking about their strengths as parents, and then you sort of realize, you know, that time has really proven quite differently that, you know, they hear these people talking about. You know, we really spend time on the weekends
和其他一切，你就像，嗯哼，嗯哼。敬请关注这本书。但，嗯，我不知道，你知道，写作的好处之一，我想是，你知道，在家工作的能力，在家陪伴的能力，拍摄关于山谷的电影，嗯，那也有帮助，是的，嗯，不要走得太远，但即便如此，我想，你知道，我不知道，当我去伦敦制作《魅影缝匠》时，他们确实来了一段时间，但后来他们明白，两个月内你不会见到我，你知道。但这没关系，一年12个月里，只要我在剩下的时间里和你在一起，
and everything else, and you're like, uh-huh, uh-huh. Stay tuned for the book. but um i don't know you know one of the one of the benefits of writing i suppose is you know the ability to work from home the ability to be present at home and shooting movies about the valley well that helps too yeah um to not to not go too far away but even still i think that you know i don't know i when i went to london to make phantom thread there was they did come for some of the time but then they understood that for two months you're not going to see me you know But that's okay, out of 12 months in a year, as long as I'm with you the other chunk of time,
你不会太想念我的。抱歉，杰森，当他说陪伴时，这意味着你在你所在的地方，并且你意识到周围的环境和其他人，等等。明白了。不仅仅是被填补。对。明白了。我会说我确实喜欢，说这个几乎是陈词滥调，但你，你。
you won't miss me that much. Sorry, Jason, when he says be present, it means that you are where you are and that you're aware of the surroundings and of other people, et cetera. Got it. Not just being filled in. Right. Understood. I will say I do love, this is almost trite to say, but you're, you're.
你对讲述洛杉矶故事的热爱，以这么多不同的方式和这么多不同的时间。我觉得它真的很迷人。你讲述加州经历的故事与众不同，因为我认为一直有那种摩擦，加州因为更新而不那么有趣，它不是东海岸，它总是以这种方式被看不起。但你讲述了这些关于它实际上有多丰富的故事。
your affinity for your love of telling stories about Los Angeles in so many different ways and so many different times. I find it really fascinating. You tell stories about the experience of California unlike anybody else because I think that there's always been that rub that California is not as interesting because it's newer, that it's not the East Coast, that it's always kind of looked down on in this way. but you tell these stories about actually how rich it is.
它只是不同。而且他们有道奇队，对吧，保罗？是的，他们有。你知道吗？嗯，是的，他们有。你是道奇队的粉丝吗？是的，我偶尔会看他们的比赛。嘿，所以塔伦蒂诺说任何伟大的电影制作人一生只有十部电影。
It's just different. And they've got the Dodgers, right, Paul? Yes, they do. You know? Well, yes, they do. Are you a Dodger guy? Yeah, I catch him up at once in a while. Hey, so Tarantino says any great filmmaker only has ten films in them.
你已经拍了九部。告诉我那不是真的。哦，那是胡扯。我不知道。我不明白他在说什么。就像，我需要你再多拍一部。你做到了，我的意思是，我不知道。
You've made nine. Tell me that's not true. Oh, that's horseshit. I don't know. I don't understand what he's on about that. It's just like, I need more than one more from you. You got it I mean I don't know
你会像克林特·伊斯特伍德那样，直到他们把你抬走吗？是的，我不知道。你必须。你还能做什么？没错。
Are you gonna You gonna do it like Clint Eastwood Until until they cart you off Yes I don't know You have to What else are you gonna do? Exactly
我想是的，你还能做什么？你必须。因为我想象你随着年龄增长，对事物的视角会发生变化。换句话说，你今天制作《私恋失调》的方式会和你当时不同。
I think yeah What else are you gonna do You have to Because I would imagine your perspective On stuff changes as you get older In other words You would have made heartate differently today than you did then
没有更好，没有更坏，只是不同。你还没拍过一部烂片。是的，我想看看当你85岁时你的大脑是什么样的，什么对你来说是有趣的，你如何构图等等。所以别停下来，拜托。嗯，谢谢。
No better no worse Just differently You haven't made one bad film Yeah, I want to see what your brain is like when you're 85, what's interesting to you and how you compose shots and all that stuff. So don't stop, please. Well, thank you.
没有更好也没有更差，只是有所不同。你没拍过一部烂片。是的，我想看看当你85岁时，你的大脑会是什么样，什么对你来说是有趣的，你如何构图等等。所以请不要停下来。好吧，谢谢你。
Thank you for saying that. Thanks for making really good shit, Paul. Yeah, Paul, you're batting average is insane. You're one of the fucking greats, man. I always tell you that when I see you in person because I can't, there's no other... I can't dress it up. I just can't dress it up, man.
谢谢你这么说。谢谢你制作了这么棒的作品，保罗。没错，保罗，你的成功率高得离谱。你绝对是伟大的天才之一，伙计。我每次见到你都会这么说，因为我没法……我没法修饰它。我真的没法修饰它，伙计。
You have really honored us with hanging out for an hour, Paul. Thank you, buddy. Are you kidding? Thank you, guys. Please say hi to my eyes. I sure will. I sure will. I sure will.
保罗，你能花一个小时和我们在一起，真是我们的荣幸。谢谢你，伙计。你说什么呢？谢谢你们。请代我向我的眼睛问好。我一定会做的。我一定会做的。我一定会做的。
I hope I see you guys in person for real soon. I hope I can come see your Oscar Levant play, Sean. I am really genuinely, I'm like, I love Oscar Levant. I would love for you too. Are you playing, who's playing Oscar Levant? That would be me. You're playing Oscar Levant? I'm playing Oscar Levant, yeah.
希望我很快能在线下见到你们。肖恩，希望我能去看你演的奥斯卡·黎凡特（Oscar Levant）的剧。我是真心实意地，我非常喜欢奥斯卡·黎凡特。我很乐意让你去看。你在演，谁在演奥斯卡·黎凡特？那个人就是我。你在演奥斯卡·黎凡特？没错，我在演奥斯卡·黎凡特。
You should hear him play Rhapsody and Blue, too, on piano. You know, he's a classically trained pianist. It's insane. Polly, thank you for being here. We love you. Thanks so much, Bob. Thank you, man. Are you kidding?
你还应该听听他在钢琴上弹奏的《蓝色狂想曲》。你知道，他是受过古典训练的钢琴家。太疯狂了。波利，谢谢你来到这里。我们爱你。非常感谢，鲍勃。谢谢你，伙计。你说什么呢？
Thanks, guys. Hopefully, we'll see out at the stadium if baseball gets their act together. Fingers crossed, they will. They will. All right. Have a great day, man. See you, man. All right.
谢谢你们。希望如果棒球联盟能解决好他们的问题，我们能在体育场见到你们。祈祷他们能做到。他们会做到的。好的。祝你今天过得愉快，伙计。再见，伙计。好的。
See you. Bye, buddy. Bye, buddy. That was a good guy, Jay. I love him. Jay, oh, my God. I mean, I've been working this for a couple of weeks with you guys saying I booked somebody that I'm excited about that you guys won't be excited.
再见。再见，伙计。再见，伙计。那是个好人，杰伊。我爱他。杰伊，天哪。我是说，我和你们一起录这个节目已经几周了，我说我预约了一位我很兴奋，但你们可能不会兴奋的嘉宾。
I tried to kind of fake it a little bit. I can't believe it. I don't know. It's fantastic. You know, it's true, though. You know, when you name all his movies for Tracy, again, I know you said at the top of this episode, but it's Boogie Nights, Magnolia, Punch Drunk Love,
我试着稍微装了一下。我简直不敢相信。我不知道。这太棒了。不过你知道，这是真的。你知道，当你列举他所有的电影时，再说一次，我知道你在本集开头提到了，但那是《不羁夜》、《木兰花》、《私恋失调》，
There Will Be Blood. There Will Be Blood. Lickish Pizza that's out now. He doesn't miss. He never misses. And there's so many years in between him making those. You're like, oh, that's why it's so long because he invests everything that he is.
《血色将至》。《血色将至》。现在上映的《甘草披萨》。他从不失手。他从未失手。而且他制作这些电影之间隔了这么多年。你会觉得，哦，这就是为什么时间这么长，因为他投入了他的一切。
And these things, that's why, what you said, nine, right? He's only made nine. Yeah. Yeah, and they've all been great. Yeah, he's, uh, what a, what a talent, that guy. I'm really, I'm just, I'm, I think I seem pretty casual all the way through that, but my goodness is that guy a hero to me. Yeah, he's amazing.
还有这些作品，这就是为什么，就像你说的，九部，对吧？他只拍了九部。没错。是的，而且每一部都很棒。是的，他，呃，真是个天才，那家伙。我真的，我只是，我想我在整个过程中看起来都很随意，但天哪，那家伙是我的偶像。是的，他太棒了。
Yeah, same. I, I, you know, I've known I'm just a little bit over the years from, through Maya, and uh, every time, I think it every time I'm always right on the edge at risk of embarrassing myself. Um, and I do end up saying stuff like, you're, you're moving. was incredible and I can't get over it. And then I have to walk away. Most of the time I have to walk away. I really, I would, I, I, I'd love for him to make some big, broad comedy.
是的，我也是。我，我，你知道，通过玛雅，这些年来我对他了解一点点，呃，每次，我每次都觉得我总是处于尴尬的边缘。嗯，我最终还是会说出一些话，比如，你的电影太不可思议了，我无法释怀。然后我就得走开。大多数时候我都得走开。我真的，我，我，我很想让他拍一些大型的、通俗的喜剧。
The ones that I know he's a fan of. Yeah, I know. I know. I know. I was going to ask him that. Yeah. I mean, I'm sure he gets that question a lot. So I'm glad none of us did because I wanted to ask him that too.
我知道他喜欢的那种。是的，我知道。我知道。我知道。我本来想问他那个问题的。是的。我是说，我相信他经常被问到这个问题。所以我很高兴我们都没问，因为我也想问他那个问题。
But like, you know, you think about his affinity for that kind of comedy, you know, Monty Python, S&L. I bet it would just be stunning, but... Yeah, he used to be around S&L so much, obviously, and I should see it. But, you know, I liked our conversation about, you know, the streaming versus the wide release stuff because, you know, the wide release movies,
但就像，你知道，你想到他对那种喜剧的喜爱，你知道，蒙提·派森（Monty Python），《周六夜现场》（SNL）。我敢打赌那一定会非常惊艳，但是……是的，他以前经常在《周六夜现场》周围转悠，显然，我应该去看看。但是，你知道，我喜欢我们关于流媒体与大规模发行电影的对话，因为，你知道，大规模发行的电影，
when you go see them, you have to pay for them. But when they're at home, they kind of feel like they're free so you don't have to... Bye! The race to the buy from you is so remarkable. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic
当你去看它们时，你必须付费。但当它们在家里播放时，它们感觉就像是免费的，所以你不需要……再见！从你那里购买的竞赛真是太引人注目了。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless是100%有机的，
and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿姆贾夫（Rob Armjarf）手工制作。Smartless。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。